[Music]
- one what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are sitting down with
Sarah Hagen hello hello thanks for
coming out of the show thank you for
inviting me I appreciate it vitalist
superfood Helia is so important because
micronutrient rich food for people that
are really trying to move around and get
healthy food and like stay busy yeah yes
so we designed this product line so
basically anybody can take what they
need on the go our intention is
ultimately to offer kiosks at in various
cities around the world specifically in
Airport so people can have something
super healthy while they're flying that
doesn't weigh them down and that's the
point of the food it's super light easy
to digest micronutrient rich and living
food so we actually it comes from a term
called life food which was coined by dr.
David Jeb and his ex-wife
Annie Jeb they came up with life food
and this is a variation on their food
combined with sort of David Wolf's theme
on super food so it kind of brings the
two together this idea of life food or
food that is doesn't weigh you down
right because I know this is probably
the most relatable example for people is
when you have the choice to eat a burger
or a salad that seems to be like the
most relatable way to get that right and
every time you eat the burger you're
like well every time you eat the salad
you're like huh you're like almost like
you said leiter yeah so so one of the
things is that we're all facing so much
stress in our lives and one of the
biggest causes of stress is actually the
impact that food has when we take it in
and the amount of work the body has to
do to break it down and assimilate the
nutrients so we try to make all of that
super easy and accessible through all of
our cuisine that's kind of the point is
that yeah easy to digest and get it in
and have it go to work so we get energy
from it rather than like
need a nap yeah yeah and the it's like
how can you make food that's so rich in
nutrient value that's easy for us to
digest and continue on with our lives I
love that mission yeah that is my
mission I love it yeah so a lot of
people have ideas about what I should do
and how I should do it and what to do
next but I'm super committed to the
product line yeah so although I have a
lot of really fabulous products that can
stand alone pretty much every one of
them can however I think the whole
product line is actually the value yeah
I came up with the product line based on
doing liver cleansing and cell
rejuvenation cleansing which dr. Jub
taught me so I spent eight years
studying with the sky and since since
that point in time he's kind of moved on
to a different path in his own life but
he released some books that sort of
speak to this and any job his ex-wife is
still doing the work in Los Angeles is
this with wellness avatar I know they
have a product line called life food
life food yes so he is life food calm
and she has like food organics and she's
in Los Angeles and he's bopping around
talking about a new topic now which
which is different off subject but so he
taught me about cell rejuvenation and
liver cleansing and basically when I
about 17 years ago I I had been on
doctor prescribed speed as a kid and so
this had a huge impact on my liver by
the time I was 21 I had very minimal
liver enzymes which meant almost
anything I ate was very difficult on
digestion I sort of became allergic to
things they became overweight I had acne
and sort of was and serious congestion
and I didn't know what to do so I became
a vegan and then vegan didn't help much
because I was allergic to soy and gluten
and and and corn and so these foods were
not reacting well which is the basis of
the vegan diet pretty much and so then I
was like well I asked this question I'm
like well what is nutrition and
I started seeking an answer to that and
ended up at these underground raw food
dinners because it wasn't on the table
at the time so people were talking about
colonics and juicing and like and chia
seeds and flax seeds and all these
conversations were very new at the time
they weren't public conversations and
during that time I met dr. David Jub I
met David Wolfe and I met Giuliano and I
helped Giuliano launch Giuliano's raw in
Santa Monica I'm at David David job who
got me doing liver cleansing and I met
David Wolfe who had me start thinking
about what are superfoods and so these
were these were kind of like the three
topics going on in my life and the
majority of the work I ended up doing
was with dr. Jobe because I started
doing liver cleansing and saw huge
changes in my health overnight and over
time and so after about three years I
had reduced all the 40 pounds I had put
on my skin had gone back to normal my
nails were strong my hair was long I was
totally radiant and so I had a complete
life change I went from looking at 24
years old something like at 40 to
looking about 19 at 32 and then then
like a slowly living in California I got
no got back on coffee and we and glutens
and things at the time but I still have
done a lot of work and even now I do
like one cleanse a year and right now I
just committed to doing two weeks myself
to just sort of reset the program yeah
but anyways so in on that program we do
blended food that contains oil and on
that program you can also have things
that ate aid in digestion
so unlike fast and juice cleanses that
are popular today to talk about we do
things that sort of stabilize blood
sugar level that are friendly to almost
anybody where they're at even diabetics
have had success on our programs where
we can take for example electrolyte
lemonade is key and are key in our
program so anybody can actually make
this at home and it can be found in dr.
Jeb's book on how to make this I do a
variation of it mine's not exactly his
recipe at all but similar and inside
this when we when we take somebody
that's diabetic we just actually grind
up flax seeds and
dürdane to further slow the blood sugar
is yes but every all of our drinks with
the exception of this one which is a
coke drink this is the only one we cook
but it's a slow extraction that shizzle
we have it as fizzle as well but this
was a little bit even more elaborate
than this one but this kit contains
approximately 17 ingredients and it's
sort of a whole body reset but this is a
slow extraction this is the only drink I
make that doesn't have a hole in it
or is our tea line mm-hmm and and some
of them have what is it like a low oil
or no so
so every single one of my products we
either use coconut oil flax oil or olive
oil coconut oil flax oil or olive oil
and then you also have some flax seed or
chia seed to slow down the blood sugar
response depends on the person that
we're dealing with so okay so to the
state like we don't in my in my drink
line we don't well that's a lie because
we put chia seeds in our protein line
and our protein drinks okay so these are
sort of designed for the person that
wants a meal that wants to get the chia
seeds and what's unique about this
versus a lot of the chia seeds on the
market is that we pre soaked the Chia in
a probiotic water and so we get the Chia
activated and then we add our milk that
we make so this one lately we've been
made using we saw this at the gym where
my test kitchen is so recently I
launched this Test Kitchen and launched
this product vital a superfood prior to
that I was doing business as well in The
Saboteur and everything was a little
cute mason jars for like five years and
by order only but so this one is the
cashew nut milk made with a Sun warrior
protein powder and we use honey honey is
another key ingredient besides oil that
we put in nearly everything I just
recently made mushrooms with honey and I
thought yeah it was so good
so yeah just like full mushrooms and
added some like tarragon and honey and
sauteed them in olive oil but I just
thought that it was so interesting
though to honey can be added to so many
things and surprisingly enough and so
you okay so coconut oils or olive oils
or flax oils flax and then so that
there's a huge benefit
having coconut oil or flax oil or
coconut oil is also a tricky food to
work with when it's not heated it can go
rancid and it can turn to soap so so we
created an emulsification base and we
only use coconut oil almost exclusively
in milk products and our milk products
are made with nuts so we make an
emulsification with coconut oil and a
lecithin and and some salt and honey and
then and then we make our nut milk and
then in the nut milk is made with
coconut oil so let's let's take a couple
steps back you you started unpacking
this this underground world yeah and I
thought that was so interesting yeah
okay so then recently we've learned
about like hydro colonics
so actually cleaning out your colon with
water and we've also been practicing I
haven't done that yet but we've been
practicing things on the show like
fasting you've done a lot of fasting on
the show done a lot of like five-day
fast three day fast fasting feels great
we've done a lot of eating just raw food
and non not even not even cooked food
and so just raw food and not not no milk
dairy or or cheese or meat and or even
refined sugars so we've tried like a lot
of things on the show and this whole
like underground world that was coming
up that you were immersing yourself in
and a lot of the underground world
actually healed like you said had to do
with like liver cleansing or colon
cleansing or just you were cell
rejuvenation these things that the
mainstream media and mainstream
nutrition doesn't really talk about
enough and there are these ways that we
can heal our body through food that you
started really being passionate about so
a few things on that is that one I would
never say anybody can heal themselves
with food but I would say that people
can set new patterns and they can get
the body where it's optimal to eliminate
or or manage whatever could be going on
that's more toxic well for example if
you have like
um irritable bowel syndrome and then and
then you stop eating the food that's
causing you the problem the body will
heal correct so we were careful about
using those I'm super careful about the
language around these things because
I've been in the field for a super long
time the pre patterning behavior is
correct and but but my whole theory and
the whole theory behind my training is
that we do upstream cleaning which is
dealing with the liver so we upstream
cleaning so you would never go to a
river and clean the bottom first
it's just gonna keep emptying emptying
back into the bottom and the bottom is
gonna run it's a good way to put it
ready so we go to the top of the liver
and we basically wring out the liver and
we get the liver better to able to
manage toxins and while we're doing that
we start to increase elimination in the
colon and the small intestine by using
herbs that contain aloe vera or
different different sort of food based
herbs that get the digestion stimulated
and moving and then we use liquid
nutrition and things that have seeds and
other sort of high fiber content so we
don't work with juice necessarily we
work with things that have all the fiber
intact
we have oils to keep the things stable
and we use oil and lemon juice and oil
and acid to sort of wring out the liver
so like a sponge we're sort of like
wringing it out wringing it out wringing
it out and then as toxins one come in
and as toxins are released the body's
better able to manage it and move it out
so we think in terms of this oh yeah
upstream so crucial that I like that
analogy a lot so you're at the top of
the stream where the water is first
starting to roll down and that's the
analogy for the liver and then now oh
how are the coconut oils and in the flax
oil in olive oil
how are they kind of like wringing out
the liver making a better combination of
the oil and the acid so one thing people
may know is that acid come from well we
so like for example the lemonade has
lemon yellow detox has lime they both
have an oil with them cool
and then and on a typical liver flush
one would one would drink some oil and
acid lemon or grapefruit and you kind of
chase one after the next but you would
want to be prepared for this so that
when what happens is it causes the
gallbladder duck to open and things and
to sort of flush and release and and
this has been tested like people can
actually collect what what residue may
come out and take it and have it you
know looked at under a microscope and
see actually what happened and what's
occurred in what's been released so on
some level there can be saponified oil
and other other other bits are like
calcified calcium stones and various
stones that have been sort of stored and
so this one also makes a point that it
pretty much almost always is a high
socioeconomic status thing to go through
a liver cleanse it's difficult to find
low SES communities of people that can
afford the time and the resources to do
a liver cleanse well somebody in an
emergency situation with the gallbladder
is you could just get a Coke and a
bottle of olive oil and sort of force it
through a coke can of coke and a bottle
of olive oil yeah and maybe you would
drink the whole bottle of olive oil but
you could do a little bit and it would
cause bladder duct to open up and
release but you know that's that's been
done we've seen it done with some but
all you need is a little bit of a little
bit of olive oil and you need the it's
not a little necessarily it's like six
to 12 ounces and then six to 12 ounces
of like lemon juice of lemon juice yeah
so that's actually not that expensive so
I mean no this doesn't hat this doesn't
know like okay but we get into this
glass jar and we I'm buying fancy oils
and fancy honey and salt and like
organic produce sort of we're getting
into a different thing but like almost
anyone could make this we're talking a
lemon water salt a sweetener and oil
shake it up don't say that tell them the
secret well then oh this is not mine
there is not that's not what I'm saying
I do so like my mind has like high-end
honey
Olive Oyl so honey and that's another
that's another really good conversation
which olive oil and honey are not
created equal so you can't just like and
that's and that's what I'm saying what
does that mean well the olive oils are
very different how they're processed
where the where the olives are grown how
they're pressed and then honey is even
more finicky than olive oil because if
honey doesn't come from a tree and it's
not raw it's it's actually all can be
more toxic than white sugar cooked honey
is more toxic than white sugar we're
gonna get all our honey when they kill
all the bees that's that's the whole
thing I mean I really do stand for
employing the bees yeah I'm like way up
there species list remember we had
Matias on our show and Matias was
talking about how he figured out how to
engineer beasts so that they could be
more productive and that was a really
interesting show with indie BIOS Matias
you just leave the bees alone they'll
engineer themselves they're doing fine
until we think you feared so okay back
to the show so so it's interesting that
there's all these different like
cleanses of this upstream area that that
occur like we need a we need to go
through this liver cleanse we need to
test this out and see what it feels like
we need to get some olive oil some lemon
juice some vitalist superfood we needed
we need to try this out and then there's
so many other like you said things that
people work on for their bodies to
cleanse that some of them aren't even
that expensive like it's that's great
but totally once you get a pearl we have
a drugstore version of this which is
like you know at home like as far as the
liver cleansing goes there is a
drugstore version yeah get some get some
lemons get some oil you can get it done
and you know but then once a
professional ends up putting together
the ingredients into a nice package and
for you to just be able to grab and go
for your patient location that's when
things can get a little bit more
expensive where they get expensive yeah
well so we you know we've upgraded all
the products so like there's nothing
everything I use is the best you can
possibly get on my ingredients that's
right I don't I don't believe in doing
anything less so I only use organics
and then I use the highest-quality honey
I use a blackberry honey that's
harvested from Oregon we have it driven
down
it's not even Sloan right that thing
gets driven to me we buy it in the 45
pound buckets Wow we go through a lot a
month like we get our we source every
ingredient that we get and then like for
example so on my on the cleanses that I
provide we also I've designed crackers
and I've designed balls and I've
designed porridges yeah let's go through
some of the things on the table this is
really the only thing that can kind of
be do it at home but it's icy even on
the way I do it is different like with
the the particular type of sea salt I
get apples and like where I get these
sources things kind of makes it unique
to how I do it and actually my my recipe
on it but in general other than this
product none of this is something that
we share how we do other than I just
will give give out the tip that if you
are to make chia at home it's good to
soak the Chia ahead of time and get it
activated because she has it has a huge
expansion rate and when it's not soaked
it doesn't behave the same way so even
if you're going to use it dried it's
good to soak it then dehydrate it and
then bring it back in like so that's a
perfect example is this cracker
so this is our Chia flax chip it's
actually not a cracker it's a chip so we
make chips and then we make crackers and
you can kind of see there's like a
difference in the width total it sort of
the way it behaves and then this is also
crackers it's a cheese cracker and then
this against the chip and so the this
chip here though is designed
specifically for fasting and cleansing
and it's flax seeds and chia seeds the
chia seeds are completely activated
before before anything happened so
you've soaked them and the dehydrated
them well then we soak them and then we
made it into this batter which is then
dehydrated and so this is a completely
raw raw chip here and it's a B vitamin
hack as well so we use some nutritional
yeast it's got a high amount of B
vitamins in it
and yeah this is one of my one of this
key things that I make and there
actually is nothing on the market place
like this right now
one of the only one and only of this
tell it the Chia the chiid of flax chip
and this one actually the the version of
this the the idea of this was sort of
designed by doctor job but his was very
different than this but this is mine and
then let's give that a taste okay great
rania wanna come on send give some food
to taste sure let's do it and then but
this is the one on the this is one that
these two are kind of the ones that I'm
Wow proud of so this thing here this is
fantastic
oh you like it what are the other
ingredients in it ingredients there's
apple cider vinegar in it please some
baking soda in it
baking soda sodium bicarbonate is a
byproduct of digestion and so we put use
a little bit of that in nutritional
yeast and then some spices wow it's
fantastic
try the so what's this again what is
this what is this what is it yeah we're
good we're gonna we're getting into this
here so this here this is the pizza
cracker so this is the cheese pizza
cracker I want to try that one try that
one first
the cheese for fasting yeah we can you
can eat this when you're fasting and our
cleanser it's a it's a it's called it
it's called the life food nutritional
cleanse is what which is designed by the
jobs and my products all fall into their
into their product line into the into
the theory behind their cleanse i've
designed products that can be used on
their cleanse which their cleanses cell
rejuvenation and liver cleansing and so
this these now this is what we get into
these like this one which is pretty
interesting so this is my cheese cracker
so vegans can eat cheese and they miss
the cheese you know the cheese chips
yeah yep so this this one cracker
yeah and it's made with other than if
she's it yeah almonds and holy now flax
and cashew cheese and
I blend I turned this into a cracker
that's completely blended so this is a
blended row that as you chew it becomes
liquid again yeah right so the whole
point is that everything is we try to
get everything as close as we can to a
blended food and then this one is like
my little like gravy thing what do you
think about the cashew cheese cracker
it's nuts
and cheese no there is no cheese in it
cash would you can make cheese from
cashews
so I blend the cashews and some
ingredients in which cashew cheese
cashew debunker Yorkies made with
almonds and flax and cashews basically
that's so find it weird or interesting
or good it's good you should get with
Willy Wonka you know and work on that
pill that he's doing until they got to
the blueberry pie yeah are we doing a
quad View right now no you know I used
to have another shop yeah so so this
this is this is the the one pizza
cracker
yeah so what's neat about this is it's
very good on its own sorry I love this
that's my favorite it's not someone I
live on that that like that cracker
actually with this tea could like
satisfy me for that I break it open look
at it we're getting now we're gonna get
over that one yeah ii nür okay so this
here is our paleo pizza cracker paleo
paleo pizza cracker that's what we call
it and it's um it's almond flour and
flax flour again and then it we
basically make a soup a spicy tomato
soup and then full of vegetables and
then we dehydrate this thing down and we
spice it up and then we call this our
pizza cracker and we do make pizza out
of it which is this guy right here
thank you yeah this also has other of
our products on it so on top oh my god
Ron try this what is this it is so good
oh and that's he's so good with the
cheese cracker right uh-huh yeah they're
kind of designed to go together it's
like kind of like it's like the perfect
sauce way
like wow yeah whoa
and um ingredients on the shizzle are
it's the the Hibiscus is a standing up
favorite the - rose hips are the
dominant thing oh good
dandelion nettle rose petals Hawthorne
berry bilberry yeah reishi mushroom
ginkgo ginseng a couple other things
she basically listed a core ingredient
list except that one's actually short a
few ingredients cuz your your beast
because you know your whole ingredient
list that's really that's awesome well I
make it well I know but at the same time
some people don't know look at how many
products she has it's hard to remember I
just want to share this real quick so
we're looking at this pizza and there's
like this little bit of a white sauce on
top and so we make a macadamia-nut
alfredo we drizzle it on this and then
this is pine nut pesto and and these are
some so like all of us around the raw
food community you've been doing these
things for years but we all kind of made
up our own version so mine is like
spinach basil parsley pine nuts and then
we we have our a spice blend that we
designed ourselves that you know that we
put into it
look adamian nut cheese that's Megan so
yeah the pine nut pesto and then that's
on the pizza cracker ya know this is our
pizza yeah so this is our note with them
there's actually sun-dried tomatoes
those are cucumbers you know your what
are they there's the key and then we
also make our own sun-dried tomatoes so
we buy the sun-dried tomatoes that we
soak them in a special oil they're in
there a restaurant there you yeah so in
the in the we do have in our Test
Kitchen we have a cafe that we deliver
with in the San Francisco radius through
door - GrubHub and what's the cafe named
vitala superfood super food is the cafe
and it's located it's located at the AMC
movie theater inside studio mix at the
AMC movie theater badass on Van Ness
so that's Van Ness and like Oh
studio made inside of Studio man yeah
and you can find us on Yelp or GrubHub
GrubHub post mates or and you deliver as
well to the San Francisco area
yep within seven miles a radius within
seven miles radius of San Francisco five
mile radius I know yeah so we have this
pizza cracker here and we can open
another one like we have another one in
this box here I'll take this one yeah
thank you okay so by the way when you
take that with you look alright give it
a buy it yeah also also give a little
shot did you get a little Suman on that
on the camera too on how beautiful it is
can we get a shot of this Johnny yeah
yeah that's what I was saying yeah I
mean really I mean come on
well I was just gonna show it to the
center camp yeah go ahead good no no
okay go to camera one and no min-cut to
one and zoom there and get I should get
a shot of me there we go are we on
program yeah okay get a good shot of
this yep good light okay so look at that
so we got we got the beautiful take it a
little bit up give me a little yeah like
that there you go on a pizza cracker
that looks so good all right we're good
back to the two shot and I'm gonna take
a bite
alright I'm coming back now
so okay so the packaging is really cool
too um it's like very kind of like will
bring will bring you back for more food
rounds no I'm good go ahead you show I
gotta work the packaging is really great
too what what inspired the Unicorn
well so ever since I was a kid like
unicorns become trendy unfortunately or
fortunately whatever
I don't know cool I don't know how to go
about that conversation but ever since I
was a kid my entire room was done in
unicorns and my favorite conversation
was about unicorns and like I wrote a
story it's about unicorns and everything
was about unicorns so I also have a line
that's very original and beyond ordinary
so we don't and that's our tagline is go
beyond ordinary we don't believe in
doing anything but that's like
conventional necessarily likewise what
we want to do is and it doesn't if all
of a sudden everyone was doing this I
wouldn't necessarily care but the point
for me is more about having something
that isn't isn't what exactly the masses
what we're what the government is
feeding us like whatever this is very
unique food in general wow this is so
amazing this is the first time I'm
trying this it's so good
so I'll just chime in and as you can see
here we also
is that my mic but here we also use the
pesto again so the pesto is really
valuable because we can use it on a
number of different things so this is
our this our zucchini pasta which you
get a totally different flavor than when
you eat it like that as a pizza you have
to order this pizza right away people
that live in San Francisco this is
actually one of our more popular things
so we can we make it with macadamia
Alfredo we have a red sauce we have a
curry sauce and we have a pesto sauce
and we just brought the pesto version of
it cuz I thought it would be neat for
you to try how different the pesto is
from one thing to the next
it just unfolds differently as its put
on something else
and if you passionately I'd be great Wow
so yeah this really it really does come
down to it like one delicious tasting
food that is easy to digest and can be
taken where you go so right now we're in
the process of building boxes so the
zucchini noodle can fit in the middle
and in the compartments there would be a
pesto and then the spices and then the
oil on the lemon and then the the
chopsticks and the napkin for you home
we may I may I just say that that that
was the most unique and delicious pizza
I've ever had
thank you that was amazing can I try the
piece of cracker a bit by itself yeah of
course
let me a little piece that's perfect
this is what it tastes like by itself
the thing is what our viewers may not
understand is they think that you know
with healthy food that's good for you it
doesn't taste good but this just throws
that idea right out the door sorry wrong
it's just really very it's very tasty
Wow we saw with the piece of cracker
tastes like by itself and it has a good
kick to it
right I like that kick yeah we spice
that thing up yeah we'll see and I also
well we're at it let's now this is our
hummus so I'm really into spice and
flavor and so I one of my favorite was
north african or that sort of
mediterranean I'm I'm always after that
I grew up on Italian food so I like the
Italian food palate and whatever and and
having worked with Giuliano he was
really like into rich heavy food where
dr. Jobe was into like oily food that
was easy for digestion so I've kind of
my cuisine set falls between the two of
them but a lot of the products I've
really designed just based on like my
own preferences so like this hummus is
made with garbanzo beans so there's a
cooked bean in it but we activate this
thing yeah the lemonade electrolyte
lemonade I would love for you to taste
this lemon apple ginger honey olive oil
tumeric sea salt Ronnie you want to come
give us a goat's are so good and then
would you like to taste the hummus on
the pizza cracker so it's done in a
different way so what are the things
that is that we'd like to make these
things so you can like you can have
whatever sauce it is that you like which
the crackers are you to get a different
sort of thing
that's our electrolyte lemonade yeah and
that's technically a cleansing product
but it's also done for rehydration so
the majority of my clients like like
aloes and lemons all the time get it
clean by filthy mind Oh what do you
think Oh Ron not with your mind to care
what do you think yeah yeah it's great
the colder it is the better it is now
it's like been sitting out a little bit
but when it's when it's cold it's crisp
and so delicious and refreshing it is
Ronnie I love this try this red pepper
harissa chickpea hummus I hope you guys
came hungry
oh yeah we did
isn't that good so now while we're
talking about that as we get into and
it's so much different than this is yeah
of course
so because well actually it would be
good if you tried this now mm-hmm
yeah because yeah well because here's
the thing so additionally uh so spend
more of our products can we pause for
just red pepper or you said chickpea
hummus this is the best hummus I've ever
because this is on here actually
oh sweet to go a little bit deeper into
this this hummus our red pepper harissa
hummus is on Honor this is our
Mediterranean taco and mmm we also make
quinoa hem tabbouleh German and we also
make a cucumber yogurt which this isn't
but it's a version of it so we sell
little jars oh no we have like more than
30 SKUs no we're just in San Francisco
really yeah I think angle that angle
that up angle that up a little for me
and then and then can you give me a
lease our Mexican tacos you said no no
this isn't the Mexican taco this is the
Mediterranean tacos Mediterranean don't
we layer this thing out it's got our red
pepper harissa hummus which is one of
our products aha it has our quinoa hemp
tabbouleh chaz black Sesame's quinoa hem
various herbs sun-dried tomatoes olive
oil spices and then we typically make a
cucumber yogurt that savory and has
meant and harissa and other things in it
which for some reason isn't on here but
and then so this is just a combination
of all of our products sort of made into
this taco the Mediterranean line and
this is our Mediterranean Zolfo all
right perfect I just did a good close-up
of it I did yeah give it a try I'm going
back to this cheeseburger
eat under the eat with your mouth Oh Ron
go Ron
Mediterranean tacos the first time I've
ever heard of a Mediterranean taco what
doesn't have a cabbage will eat the rest
completely gluten free lethal hola
before I even put it in my mouth it just
smells so amazing you can smell the mint
and it looks so beautiful oh it's just
like Ron was right Ron just said that
people think that eating healthy has to
be eating food that doesn't taste as
good but this is better
actually that's part of the point is
that it's when I became a vegan it was
really awful because it was like mmm now
what I'm not a vegan anymore but I'm
mostly vegan if you had to choose only
one living meat to eat what would it be
I mean yeah I don't like to eat the
animals when I do have something to eat
it's fish anyway and I like trout fish
from the lake I feel like it would be
something a true ancient catch oh my god
that was so good I have to try this
pasta now Ron come try his pasta with me
sure Wow oh my oh this dessert sweet
sour nacho line which I didn't bring it
in the nacho cheese but we make a cashew
spicy nacho cheese and then we serve
this with a mushroom Oh wakka moly and
so we have this whole nacho hack how how
does now I have to ask this question
because people at home are wondering
like most people only go with one
product line or at most two product
lines right how did you oh my gosh who
may I
how is this pasta mmm that's so good mmm
you must order from vitala super food go
to vitae go to vitala super food calm an
order from there San Francisco location
and order food to your house as soon as
possible and try this food that is so
good it's organic but if you have to
have an animal we do offer chicken out
of the cow even though it's we don't we
don't cook inside the things we buy it
we buy organic rotisserie chickens and
shred them but there's no bread well at
least we got them to eat more than one
bite there's no bread well you've only
taken one buy those are zucchini noodles
we call them zoodles we cut these on a
mandolin there and they're nice and
thick - they remind you of like thicker
pasta so okay so this was fantastic as
well oh my goodness
okay so go and order as soon as possible
from vitala superfood or go to the AMC
on Van Ness and go to their cafe and
order have a party locator and they'll
cater your freaking party if idlest
super food catered would be like the
best food at the party ever so I feel so
blessed to be trying all this it's so
amazing okay now the question was how do
you how does one person decide on you
know 5 or 10 or even 15 products like
you have here versus starting what did
you even start off with and how did you
decide to go to 15 and how do you manage
all 15 of these products well what
happened that we have more than that but
what happened what happened is I
designed a cleanse line so people could
do a liver cleanse that wanted to liver
cleanse
and then they and then I was like well
you really need the crackers mm-hmm so
then I so so I was like okay well make
the chips then I made the chips but then
I was like but I like the cheese
crackers so then I had to make the
cheese crackers and I was like well when
you're on the cleanse you can also could
technically eat pizza so then I was like
well then we'll add the pizza so then I
had the pizza cracker and then the stuff
that you can put on top of it cause it's
all blended so you can get away with a
little bit of heavier see personally I
ran on a cleanse of like food cleanse
for almost three years so I I was on a
raw food diet almost exclusively blended
like food for about approximately three
years and when you're going that deep
into something you really want to be
entertained by food yeah and so overall
once somebody gets their health started
going which is why I like doing a liver
cleanse is very different than just like
changing to a diet because if you change
your diet you don't necessarily attack
some of the issues the underlying issues
like Candida which like I don't know if
you can see it on me or if you don't
know much about it but like right now
you can see I have a little bit more
Candida than it's necessary it's from
comes from eating bread and cheese and
you see food
what's qdd candida is an overgrowth of a
particular type of yeast and bacteria in
the digestive tract which occurs when
food is fermenting and food ferments one
when you eat food that's high in yeast
and such as cheese and bread and wine
and fruit on top of these things so
fruit and nuts don't really necessarily
go together so we don't really do that
here in general we with the exception of
some dessert which we usually recommend
eating first but and overall we don't
try we try to put everything so it's
like low Candida footprint and but one
of the things about this conversation is
that you want to get the system back in
order and then consider what you eat
moving forward so if the systems not an
order and you switch to a healthy diet
doesn't necessarily mean you're gonna
have a transition what you might this is
why cleansing is powerful is because you
want to get the system in order then you
want to then you want to consider what
are your food choices and if you're
gonna make bad food choices you
to spread them out because because it's
it's the cumulative effect of day after
day after day on something that has the
highest impact the elk head test in
these popular tests that are running now
where people can see like what they're
in tolerances are and things can often
be fixed by just simply rotating the
foods it's facing a mountain out by
three to five days it it sounded like
you said that this whole accumulation of
bacteria in your gut yeast you said in
your gut came from eating a lot of the
cheese's and stuff over and over and
over and over you're not spreading it
out I was just trying this
um the both the aloe detox and the green
jazz and I just loved how there was
still you can see there's still some of
the you know the goodies that are you
know you can still there's still some
like of these little chunks of the
goodies in there so it's not all soup I
like that about it and it adds texture I
really like that and it tasted really
good I want to I want to say that you
said that you were starting with drinks
as long as you're saying this but yeah
this this is actually like you can see
the speckles and things like you were
mentioning but this this is a food this
isn't a drink so and one of the things
that I've noticed so food yeah when I
run people through this is a food right
here this yeah that's totally food and
this is a food as well this is the whole
lemon the whole Apple the everything is
still in here as it once was it's just
basically two three hundred times and
with the exception of this we only pulse
the mint in just to keep the bitter down
as much as we can because this is a very
bitter drink which is incredibly good
for they loved it though for the for the
this is this is my this is personally
the one I drink the most because it has
the most benefit so we use the whole
aloe plant we're like you can go to the
marketplace and you can buy some like
aloe with citric acid and potassium
sorbate you can eat out what you can eat
aloe we use the skin and the gel in this
and the skin actually helps shrink the
intestinal tract and help elimination
and the gel cools and sort of brings the
hydration back into the body
so this and we also use spear
so this is a protein machine this thing
is a machine right here this is like a
very very very highly sophisticated
product and it just looks pretty simple
but the eggs I think feel the effects of
this food I feel it yeah so this is this
is a very interesting thing though but
this drink is that's awesome wrong one
of the most this one this is this and
this are like probably the two products
I'm most proud of designing and part of
the reason I designed this line is
because I really personally like to on a
daily basis feel like I did something
for my health
no matter what else I'm doing and if I
drink one of these two drinks I know I
did there's no question in my mind about
it I for sure took care of me today and
so I think that's like first priority we
all need something that we can do on a
daily basis where we feel like no matter
what I hit the mark mm-hmm and then we
can then we can keep adding on to that
and the nice thing about the vital is
superfood line and having all of this
available is like anytime you eat if you
choose it you did something for yourself
like out of the bat you can eat a pizza
and you're like I have to eat pizza
today and then you can eat it you can
film it so that so like when I
originally was hired by celebrities and
CEOs and things like this so I would I
worked at a restaurant and then I
started getting passed around the
Hollywood scene when I was younger and
the the hack was always like being able
to take a lemonade like this and I can
hide MSM which is organic sulfur which
is incredibly bitter and like no one
wants to eat it and I can hide it in
there and I can hide I can hide people
as other food Hawk yes oh and like this
this is like when I have the clients and
they like because because you take the
Chia's and you you actually let the
Chia's absorb water and you let them
soak and then you put them in the drink
and so that's why you can still taste it
kind of it's a little like bubble tea
smaller little bubbles and they're
actually really fun to like chew and
drink and you know it makes for a fun
drink and you have two of these you have
the vanilla and the cacao there was our
15-minute timer let's give that a flip
and okay so now and I know that we have
a couple other things that we need to
try you were saying earlier that you
went from starting your most proud of
your aloe detox drink which is freakin
amazing in the shizzle
oh and that I have suits the seams
aren't here but like when we talk about
the allergy talks that shows oh let me
of these soups which often when people
are talking about raw soups there this
blender puree of something and it's like
you know eating this cold puree of
things all of our soups have texture and
flavor so we we spice the things up so
we have like a sunchoke leek soup that
has fennel and it's crunchy so we make a
thing at the bottom and then we have
like nuts through our spinach basil soup
so as you're eating it you get to kind
of chew your way through the soup and
it's curly but there but there there's a
high in flavor and good in and texture
and everything so that so that's kind of
summarizes our liquid line and then yes
we have savory in you what you had a
little order here because you went with
initially making the liver cleanse and
then you had the supplement of the chips
with the liver cleanse and then you
decided to put the pizza ingredients on
the beats a chip and so that's how you
slowly built up your line over time
that's really interesting most people
will you actually built out one idea
than a secondary idea that complemented
the ideas which is that's the dessert
right now the Choate with the choco chia
choco drop chocolate chip chocolate chia
choco drop Chia so then this is instead
of a protein bar so it's a protein
protein powder walnut she walk ilat Wow
thing but this is our protein bar
basically and we try to make them look
like cookies walnut chocolate powder
coconut oil sea salt cause you know one
of the things we like to do is trick the
brain around
mmm-hmm trick the brain so it thinks
it's getting jump-cuts getting you know
the first ingredients Shia and the
second ingredients walnut yeah that's so
good yeah
and then we have these well this is but
this is better this is a little bit more
interesting because one of the reasons
these exists is that we can make pies
that people can eat while they're on
trays awesome yeah so instead of having
pies now we just put them in little jars
so anybody can like feel like they're
getting their little baby food dose and
dessert dessert and this is actually how
I originally attracted clients that they
wanted to eat dessert and they and they
didn't want to have to feel bad about it
so these are all gluten-free dairy-free
sugar white sugar free oh honey free
wishes we use honey yeah lemon Nicias
whip wrong let's see this girl
well what is it again lemon Isha's whip
holy cow
so this one is specifically like a liver
on the liver cleanse yeah we use your
own oil and we make that for the liver
cleanse your Auckland we make them in
all kinds of flavors we have any
chocolate one and then we have the
raspberry why me it was probably rhubarb
and we enjoyed makes very surprised very
whip so we just did the lemon with the
lemon ish whip versus the raspberry with
the chocolate people go crazy with whip
orange whip three orange whips you don't
member that I'm dating myself there John
Candy and the Blues Brothers delicious
holy cow mmm I actually got to work with
Dan Aykroyd he was one of my clients and
the strawberry rhubarb whip is designed
around dan Aykroyd
he loved strawberry rhubarb dessert so
one day they were like can you make a
strawberry rhubarb thing and so I made
the hack the the frozen pie and then
that they that got him
I love dan Aykroyd wasn't he he was yes
he was
one of the Blues Brothers what yeah no
you were good yeah no that was good I
mentioned the Blues Brothers no that was
a good segue feel so bad what a great
way to get a dose of dessert like in a
little you know like you said a baby
food jar so that way you're just getting
a little bit of dessert tastes amazing
on the raspberry whip you add the crust
walnut and then you have a vanilla and
sea salt and then cashew and coconut so
we used to make the Irish moss but
there's been some controversy around
Irish moss lately carried you what's
Irish what's the Irish moss controversy
um some people feel that it's
inflammatory you're not good for this or
that but I wouldn't agree but I might
just kind of musk it's in that almond
milks and it's got some controversy so
this is one of my newest products very
yeah but so unicorn balls this actually
could just kind of our promotional name
this is peanut butter it's so good yes
so the peanut butter ones were designed
for a child originally and then the
chocolate but these are different than a
lot of the superfood balls on the market
don't have a they're like ground down
things and they're very they don't have
a lot of texture going on these have a
lot of texture so they're there's some
balls going around the community the
interior these are bars again and these
are these are done so when you go to the
gym and you want to workout you don't
want to feel way down you know you're
gonna drink your water you can eat one
or two of these and then as you drink
the water it's gonna slightly expand in
your stomach but only to give you more
energy so it's a high protein high
energy calorically dense for a small
thing packed meal so this is like this
is a two of these you're not you're not
really getting above 300 calories but
that 300 calories is a very small small
things you actually eat and we call them
unicorn balls because there's nothing
really like it on the market actually
it's a massive amount of seeds it's a
very clean protein powder no coconut oil
that it is you rock
can you get a zoom in on the inside of
this ball I on the inside you one of the
peanutbutter tooth is they're really
different I have a have a little bit
here yeah the inside the inside of the
unicorn balls what's really interesting
about the inside of these balls is that
when you bite into it
keep that up where do you bite into it
the inside it looks like a planet of
seeds like it really it looks like a
planet and like that's it's like a
diverse seed count in there there's so
many of them yeah and we're not labeling
right right now cuz I'm a little bit
like until we fully launched I've kind
of tried to protect everything as much
as possible because they're beautiful so
many I mean I've already seen a lot of
my things copied and duplicated from
anybody that brought me in as a
consultant so yeah that's what happens
when you're brewing at night and I also
like on another note almost all the
ideas I got it came from somebody else
myself so it's like no no chef is like
absent from their their products being
learned from that's right wrong but we
want to share you know like we want
people to learn from us and I find it as
flattery when somebody copies me for the
most part but and hopefully they feel
the same for anything that they feel I
copied yes I improved upon its I'm so
original you know actually a big it's a
big compliment when people take what
you've made and they copy it it's a big
compliment because it's a testament to
what you've achieved so holy cow we have
everything from delicious liver
cleansing mic and just across from from
oils and acids all the way to chia seeds
well I just want to make a remark
because we've gotten a little bit like
because it we've labeled it as a cleanse
doesn't mean that's what it is
exclusively really this is a perfect
post-workout drink this is a perfect
morning drink it rehydrates your system
quickly I prefer this one before a bed
but you can take it anytime a day so
like a lot of my client
stock up on like these and they get a
couple of salads and some unicorns and
they just keep their refrigerator
stacked like wise and that originally we
were gonna call it stash stash food
because it looks like yeah like you can
basically it's really good to have these
staples in your kitchen like if you have
a cracker like this you can put whatever
the heck you want on it
avocado we make an avocado toast oh
that's great that's a good one just got
it like this really beautiful easy hack
for your kitchen that you can you know
use any one of these bases to turn it in
anything like ice and then you can put
salmon on those crackers exactly in like
even with that taco for example we make
it out of like our staple products and
the pizza we make out of our staple
products so it's it's kind of good that
anybody can kind of have some of these
things in the refrigerator and they can
sort of take care of one element of
their day easily and or all of them if
they wanted to really go so so we have
some four really hydrating in the
morning with oil and acid we have some
really good aloe aloe and ginger for and
other deliciousness in the in the detox
and evening we have some really great
Chia protein and milk for post-workout
and that's I mean if you have a milk
line as well and this is without mushiya
in it milk line without the chi in it
this is just this is just that this is
just drinks then these got complemented
by these other stash products and soup
these stash products are like you know
just being able to walk over there and
grab one of these either Chia crackers
or cheese cracker or pizza cracker and
then put a little avocado on it or a
little bit of the macadamia nut cheese
cashew nacho cheese and then we have
this Mediterranean taco this cabbage
leaf with all this delicious red pepper
harissa chickpea hummus on it mint and
and cucumber or zucchini and then the
pesto the pesto that's on the pizzas
also baked into these zoodles here and
it's just so so good
stirred in I mean I meant it's so funny
because I say baked in in not
referencing actually
taking it I meant baked in like it's
baked into the cost kind of a thing yeah
yeah yeah so so we got zoodles with
pests of there and then the dessert line
is amazing the superfood lemon is just
whip the superfood raspberry whip just
such a good way to to just grab a grab a
dessert and just be done with a little
bit of dessert and sweet that's actually
good these are so good for like you said
working out these are the unicorn balls
peanut butter and then the chocolate as
well I mean you're just you're just
doing such an amazing diverse job at
starting a company and also distribute
across San Francisco and then also just
you know you you did it based on the
need the need of getting of like
cleansing the body getting
micronutrients and making it easy to
absorb and like we're so grateful to
have vital a superfood on the show and
that hopefully we can make vitalist
superfood stashes inside of like
people's houses their corporate offices
the workout areas across the world yeah
that's the goal let's do it yeah so
right now we're working on raising money
I've so far funded this on my own and
and we want to expand and so you know
there's different people I'm talking to
but maybe you know some people are
thinking about considering doing a
restaurant or moving more into that
space with some of the more the the
foods and that other people are
interested in helping get it packaged up
more so we can move it a bit more around
the planet and then I personally am
passionate about retail shops where we
just sort of sell prepackaged items made
out of commercial kitchen that people
can easily just pre-order or hit the
button or get the thing and get get out
yep because because really like that's
how I feel about my food I don't want to
spend so much time weighing down my food
most of the time and then sometimes I
want to sit down and have a delicious
meal but in general I just like want to
make sure if something healthy to go
grab this sit back down continue emails
take you could take a couple sips and
grab and go with a little pizza on the
go you can eat it as you go I mean it's
kind of a hack it is it's this is a huge
life hack it's created a massive
life hack and we're like we're so
grateful you know while you're talking
about how you how you're all you know
you're invested deep into it yourself
funded it yourself I was thinking about
all of the connections we have in the
hospitality sector out here and people
that would absolutely love your product
line and working with you so we'll
definitely make those connections let's
see what we can do we'll make those
connections and see what we can do and
will point them in the direction of the
video as well and be like check out what
we just broke down like this whole hour
of conversation of breaking down all of
your different or your different foods
and I just like I can't get over that
this even exists in the world Ron Ron
said it really beautifully earlier which
was that most people think of healthy
food as I have to having a sacrifice
taste but here this actually is not only
healthier but tastes better as well and
that's just the biggest mind explosion
when you can get those two things mixed
together healthier and tastes better
that's it right there so if you want to
come by or you want to place an order if
you just let ourselves know or put in
your little comment box unicorn balls
we're happy to throw a couple unicorn
balls in for you so thanks for tuning in
and trying my food we loved having you
on the show sir it's such a pleasure and
let's put so the link below is in the
bio to vital a superfood go check them
out at the AMC on Van Ness and O'Farrell
in their Test Kitchen there and in their
cafe go try their food out order their
food as well let's see if we can bring
vital a superfood and just healthier and
and faster and better tasting food to
the world together let's see what we can
do here go beyond ordinary go beyond
ordinary we love it thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it if
you guys had a good time definitely give
us a subscribe give us a like comment
below your thoughts about the episode
and share it with other people and like
we always say don't just consume go
create with this if you saw and were
inspired by vitala superfood and these
different types of ways to augment our
health go and do it yourself
go and make yourself write about it make
a video about it go and make something
show your parents
your friends the healthier food the
tastier food options that exist in the
world go do that help support us on
patreon so we can continue making the
studio reality and bringing on amazing
people like Sara onto the show and
highlighting their beautiful things that
they're building into the world so thank
you very much everyone for tuning in
thank you Ron Vargas are producing
partner thank you everyone and we'll
catch you soon peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]